BRIT CRUISE: After World War II,
with most of Europe in ruins,
tension grew between the Soviet
Union and the United States.
It was clear that the next
global superpower required
the ability to both launch
and successfully defend
nuclear attacks from
intercontinental ballistic
missiles.
In North America, the most
vulnerable point of attack
was over the North Pole.
So in 1958, a joint effort
between United States
and Canada was established known
as NORAD, or North American
Aerospace Defense Command.
An important line of defense
was the semiautomatic ground
environment.
It was an automated system of
over 100 long-distance radars
scattered across North America.
They were connected to
computerized radar stations
that transmitted tracking data
using telephone lines or radio
waves.
All of this radar information
was fed into a primary Warning
Center buried a mile deep inside
Cheyenne Mountain in Colorado.
This application of machine
to machine communication
allowed operators to make
split-second decisions
using information transmitted
and processed automatically
by computers.
This idea of being online was
quickly adapted and advanced
by universities in
the following years
as they understood the potential
of computer networking.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
SPEAKER 1: The thing that makes
the computer communication
network special is that it puts
the workers, that be the team
members who are geographically
distributed, in touch
not only with one another,
but with the information
base with which they
work all the time.
And this is obviously going to
make a tremendous difference
in how we plan, organize,
and execute almost everything
of any intellectual consequence.
If we get into a mode in
which everything is handled
electronically and your
only identification is
some little plastic thing
you stick into the machinery,
then I can imagine
that they want
to get that settled up with your
bank account just right now,
and put it through
all the checks.
And that would require network.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
BRIT CRUISE: Money
transfers were
just one of a growing
number of applications which
required encryption
to remain secure.
And as the internet grew
to encompass millions
around the world, a
new problem emerged.
At the time, encryption
required two parties
to first share a secret
random number, known as a key.
So how could two people
who have never met
agree on a secret shared
key without letting
Eve, who is always listening,
also obtain a copy?
In 1976, Whitfield
Diffie and Martin Hellman
devised an amazing
trick to do this.
First, let's explore how this
trick is done using colors.
How could Alice and Bob
agree on a secret color
without Eve finding it out?
The trick is based on two facts.
One, it's easy to mix two colors
together to make a third color.
And two, given a
mixed color, it's
hard to reverse it in order to
find the exact original colors.
This is the basis for a lock.
Easy in one direction.
Hard in the reverse direction.
This is known as a
one-way function.
Now, the solution
works as follows.
First, they agree publicly
on a starting color.
Say, yellow.
Next, Alice and Bob both
randomly select private colors
and mix them into
the public yellow
in order to disguise
their private colors.
Now, Alice keeps
her private color
and sends her mixture to Bob.
And Bob keeps his private color
and sends his mixture to Alice.
Now the heart of the trick.
Alice and Bob add
their private colors
to the other person's
mixture and arrived
at a shared secret color.
Notice how Eve it is unable
to determine this exact color,
since she needs one of their
private colors to do so.
And that is the trick.
Now to do this with numbers,
we need a numerical procedure,
which is easy in one direction
and hard in the other.